in this video I'll demonstrate my
technique for creating the animated
elements featured in the neon and analog
glitch packs
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I am the
creator of motion science before we get
started I want to invite you to join my
complimentary workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes don't miss out on this chance to
level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you won't regret it in
today's video I'm revealing my method
for creating the vibrant shape layer
animations seen in the neon and analog
glitch packs which are available for
purchase over at aejuice.com check the
video description for a link now there
are two ways to create quick moving
shape animations in After Effects
keyframing each shape layer by hand
which is time consuming or using a
plug-in like shape monkey from ebberts
and Zucker I personally chose the latter
method when creating the neon and analog
glitch packs as it allowed me to save a
significant amount of time shapemonkey
is a great plug-in for specific needs
and it is also experimental which I
found to be fun and exciting it allows
me to input values experiment with
different variables and play around the
process starts with selecting the
parameters that I want to experiment
with and adjusting their values I then
hit the do it button and within seconds
I get a composition full of shape layer
animations if the animation doesn't look
as I expected I immediately undo the
action and try again with different
parameter values the process is fun and
I keep experimenting until I achieve the
desired animation I'm looking for
another important aspect that I
experiment with is the fills and
outlines of the shapes I adjust their
colors their Styles and other properties
until I achieve the look that I want
then then I play around with the number
of copies to achieve the overall amount
of shapes and speed that I am looking
for in the animation it's important to
note that even though the composition
may look like it only has a single layer
if I click the shy guy icon you'll see
that there are many shape layers within
my composition this is because the shape
monkey plug-in creates multiple shape
layers within the composition allowing
me to have more control over the
animation and make changes to individual
shape layers if needed in the
shapemonkey plug-in parameters I chose
to work with gray values as the base for
my shape layers this allows me to add
the colorama effect to an adjustment
layer on top of the composition and
input intensity or Luma values to
trigger a variety of colors the colorama
effect essentially Maps the gray values
to a color spectrum so the darker the
gray value the darker the color and vice
versa this gives me more control over
the final animation as as I can adjust
the intensity of the gray values to
achieve the desired color palette from
this point I add a glow effect to the
animation there are multiple ways to
achieve a glow effect in After Effects
one of which is to use the built-in glow
effect however in this case I prefer to
use a third-party glow plug-in from plug
in everything the Deep glow effect
offers more control and customization
options over the built-in glow effect in
After Effects now at this stage I want
to apply a look to the animation that
requires a background solid but I don't
want that solid background layer to be
affected by the colorama or glow effects
to achieve this I take the current
composition and create a new one also
known as pre-composing or pre-comping in
this new composition I add a background
solid layer then I add a couple of
third-party effects over the top of the
layers to achieve the desired look it's
important to note that similar retro
video looks can be created in After
Effects without the use of these plugins
but for the sake of time and ease of use
I prefer to use them if you're
interested in seeing how I create retro
video looks without third party effects
you can check out the linked video here
by pre-compying the composition and
adding a background solid layer that is
not pure black I am able to apply the
desired look without affecting the
colorama or glow effects that were
applied to the original composition this
allows for more control and flexibility
in the post-production process finally
after viewing the animation in motion I
decide that we best served as a vertical
piece so I resize my composition my
pre-comp and all solid layers to fit
within my new composition size this
allows me to adjust the animation to a
different aspect ratio making it more
suitable for vertical video formats such
as social media stories mobile videos
and vertical ads and there you have it
my process for creating the animated
elements that can be found in the neon
glitch and analog glitch pack tax Linked
In the description below I hope this is
both educational and enjoyable for you
and if you enjoyed this video please hit
that like button and consider
subscribing to my YouTube channel for
more content just like this I would love
to hear your thoughts on this video so
please leave any comments or questions
below thank you for watching and I look
forward to connecting with you in my
next video
[Music]
foreign